quiero hablar un poco más con respecto a
la reflexión difusa y especular y para
comenzar quiero hacer una corrección
menor al vídeo anterior y de hecho es
una corrección bastante interesante
porque esa imagen de aquí de la
izquierda cuando hable de un doble
reflejo mencioné que la luz del sol caía
acá caía de aquí acá al agua y de acá al
agua caía al remo y del remo a nuestra
vista pero alguien comentó con justa
razón que en realmente en este punto no
es donde se refleja hacia el remo aquí
es el reflejo que va directo a nuestros
ojos por lo que la luz que cae hacia el
remo la luz que se refleja en el remo va
a caer primero del sol con un ángulo un
poquito más superficial en el agua
del agua esta parte nosotros nos vemos
es el reflejo porque es el que está con
dirección al remo y ahora sí del remo se
refleja a nuestros ojos y de nuevo
quiero aclarar que nosotros no vemos los
rayos del sol que se están reflejando en
el reyno porque la luz o la imagen va en
dirección del remo y después llega a
nuestros ojos en cambio está este
reflejo de acá si está llegando directo
a nuestros ojos esa es una muy
interesante percepción de lo que sucede
en este caso de la reflexión hay otra
cosa de la que les quiero hablar con
respecto a reflexiones especulares y
difusas que ocurren simultáneamente cada
vez que ustedes observan un objeto
brillante que no sea un espejo como por
ejemplo
esta brillante y rica manzana de acá
como podemos ver este círculo brillante
en esta bonita manzana es un reflejo de
la fuente de luz y alrededor de ella
solo vemos el color de la manzana que
está pasando aquí
fuera dibujar la superficie de esta
manzana vamos a dibujarlo en un color
neutral más o menos así la superficie de
la manzana y aquí arriba vamos a tener
una fuente de luz que va a estar bueno
escribo de hecho es fuente de luz un
foco o algo así fuente de luz
pues va a estar emitiendo luz que va a
estar cayendo
en la superficie de la manzana
o menos indirectamente por encima
y lo que sucede es que en la superficie
bueno ocurre en un par de cosas
algunos de estos rayos de luz se
reflejarán es peculiarmente es decir que
van a mantener la imagen del objeto que
los está iluminando que los está
enviando entonces va a reflejarse así
más o menos
uno de estos rayos manteniendo su
proporción
o su ángulo
y recibos con línea punteada porque no
toda la energía de la luz es reflejada
sólo una parte
vemos que aquí está el rostro de alguien
aquí va a estar su nariz sus labios su
mentón
ojos
su oreja y me quedo medio extraño aquí
pelo etcétera bueno
esta persona ver a una razonable versión
de la fuente de luz ya que eso está
siendo reflejado hacia sus ojos
el resto van a reflejar la luz de manera
difusa y van a reflejar
el color rojo de la superficie de la
manzana
estos rayos como se reflejan de manera
difusa pues algunos pueden aquí pueden
reflejarse así este reflejarse hacia acá
este a lo mejor así
en fin
y la superficie de la manzana va a
absorber los colores que no son rojo
amarillo o esos tonos que vemos en la
superficie y esos son los que va a
reflejar y por lo tanto son los que
vamos a poder ver así que debido a que
la manzana no es totalmente lisa tiene
partes rugosas algunos elementos del
rayo de luz de la fuente van a
reflejarse especular mente y otros
difusamente por lo que lo que vemos en
este punto en donde tenemos la reflexión
especular es donde vemos más o menos la
fuente de luz la imagen de la fuente de
luz y en todos los demás puntos de la
superficie vamos a ver la luz reflejada
difusamente es por eso que si movemos la
manzana o si nos movemos de donde
observamos a esta este punto de
reflexión va a cambiar conforme se mueva
imaginemos que tenemos a una persona a
otra persona que está viendo a esta
manzana está de perfil y aquí estaba más
o menos su cara
una expresión sorprendida de ver esta
manzana tan grandota
al menos en comparación con el rostro de
esta persona
esta persona está mirando a esta manzana
él no va a ver este punto blanco de luz
de acá el ver a esta parte blanca en
donde en su línea de vista caigan los
rayos de la luz directo a la superficie
que caigan los rayos de luz
claro imaginando que la fuente de luz se
encuentra aquí arriba es decir que esto
va a rebotar directamente
asia
la línea de vista de esta persona donde
si nosotros dibujamos aquí una
perpendicular a la superficie de la
manzana en este punto
veremos que el ángulo que se forma entre
el rayo de luz que cae en la manzana
y el rayo de luz que rebota de la
manzana
son los mismos el ángulo incidente es
igual al ángulo reflejado así que en
esta sección donde tendrá o se podrá ver
el reflejo especular pero en todos los
demás puntos de la superficie de la
manzana ser verdad la reflexión difusa
que llegará a sus ojos en forma de luz
roja
así difuso por todos lados y es por eso
que esta persona verá la reflexión
especular más o menos por acá en esta
parte verá este punto blanco nosotros
como estamos de este lado pues vemos el
punto de reflexión en donde la luz cae
de la fuente y se refleja directamente
hacia nuestros ojos por supuesto que la
luz también cae en esos otros lugares
pero se refleja hacia donde nuestros
ojos no se encuentran por lo que en su
lugar solo vemos el reflejo difuso que
llega a nuestros ojos espero que esto
haya ayudado a llenar algunas de las
dudas que quedaron en el vídeo anterior